[Music]
hey everybody i'm dave ramsey and today
i'm excited to give you exclusive access
to a talk i gave recently at entree
leadership master series now this isn't
something we do all the time leaders
from all over the country pay thousands
of dollars to attend master series every
fall
because it's an incredible conference
if you're a business owner who wants to
take your leadership to the next level
then you should use the link below to
learn more
let's get to it
decision making is a process there's a
lot of decision making frameworks a lot
of decision making paradigms but the the
idea that the decision has to be made
when you're the leader i have to be
decisive it does not have to be
instantaneous but i have to be decisive
to put my name my picture under the word
leader passivity is not an option
you must make decisions
to lead
passive leader is an oxymoron
calm
gentle
slow
leader is not an oxymoron
loud wild
getum leader is not an oxymoron that's
fine i don't care what your style is but
passively sitting and letting everything
happen to you and happen to your
organization while you should be making
the call
is not okay
your business your ideas and your team
will be paralyzed by an indecisive
leader
i have leaders on my team that are very
deliberate they need all the details
they need time emotionally to process it
and they make decisions very slowly and
i am fine with that
as long as they make the freaking
decision
i have leaders on my team that are like
me i'm a super high d i make a decision
if i don't like it or it's wrong i'll
just make another one
like in the next 13 seconds you know
i'm fine with that
so that that's just the speed at which
you're doing it neither one is correct
what the only thing that's incorrect is
simply not doing it that's not okay an
indecision in general the paralysis of a
decision facing you and you not doing
anything is only caused by one thing
fear
we all have things come at us that we
fear that we don't understand we don't
know what to do with
and
not dealing with them means the fear won
the argument
and fear is not a fruit of the spirit
the bible says that a double-minded man
is unstable in all his ways
sometimes people are like that squirrel
on the road y'all got squirrels in your
area
and they run out the road and they go
boom
that's a double-minded man you're gonna
get run over
i don't care if you're left or right
just be it
that way you don't get hit by the truck
just be what you is somebody's not gonna
like whatever you do and you're gonna be
dead in the road if you decide you're
going to try to please everybody so just
get out of the road
make a decision
right
criticism
comes with the territory
the only way to avoid criticism
aristotle said is to do nothing say
nothing and be nothing
these are not options
my friend max lucado says his daddy used
to say
dogs don't bark at parked cars
the trolls are there the criticism's
going to be there you're going to make
mistakes and people are going to
misunderstand your motives oh well
criticism is going to come
if you are
if it is necessary in your personality
for you to keep everyone happy you will
destroy your mental health
you simply cannot keep everyone happy
i don't want to be unkind to someone i
don't want to
purposefully pick fights unless it's for
the entertainment value but
but in general i'm not i'm not trying to
go out here and just rough people up
that's not the point but the point is i
am well aware that as long as i do
anything of scale the scale of criticism
is going to continue to stay with it
it goes
with the territory
some of it's close to you it's your
mother the lady earlier
some of it's you know if team members or
former team members or
sometimes it's a customer uh sometimes
it's a competitor uh and sometimes
people that just make up crap
and so just count on it trolls
cancel culture
fear of covet mandates of one kind or
another
this is all you know managing if you
manage to the optics if you lead to keep
everybody happy that you lead you're one
of these companies that leads to make
everybody happy you want you want to
look like you like that you did the
right thing you love everybody you're
going to get nothing done
you're of no value if you completely
neutered your whole process
because you have no soul left
you become agnostic to everything
anything is okay everything is okay
so nothing is okay
and that's what a lot of these publicly
traded companies have done they're
trying to take these stands where all
the little groups and all of their
little problems are all addressed when
they're supposed to just be selling
stuff at their store
and instead they've gotten in the
political business and in the political
correct business politically correct
business trying to keep from getting
cancelled
by somebody
well there's a good way to keep from
getting canceled by the way
own it
a little tough to cancel me on the
network
now i'm not trying to be offensive to
some group or whatever i'm not setting
out to do that but i'm also not going to
live in fear that we're going to get
business done we're going to love people
well we're going to be kind and we're
going to be excellent at what we do and
because we're moving things around
somebody's pissed
all the time
just get used to it
it's part of the process elements of
good decision making deciding not to
decide can be the right decision
sometimes you don't have enough
information sometimes it's in the heat
of the moment you need to calm down so
sometimes just saying not right now
that is a decision
it's an intentional act
it's proactive it's not passive and
you're simply saying
not right now
not right now
not right now
not right now not ready to pull the plug
not ready to pull the plug we're not
doing that when everything was melting
down last year
an account and we're drop we're losing
events moment by moment by moment every
day another event was getting we were
having to cancel it i suddenly we had
people out there five six months out
from the current situation with covid's
stuff stirring up right we got people
five six seven months out trying to
cancel something i'm like how the crap
do you know what's gonna be happening in
seven months
i'm not canceling that today
when we get a little closer if the same
kind of environment exists we may have
to cancel it but today i'm not canceling
stuff the whole thing may be over out
there in seven months i don't know and
you know
what kind of looking glass have you got
that you can look eight months in the
future know exactly what is going to
happen
you know no
so
we didn't cancel stuff and it made
everybody nervous and they would like be
in my office every day can we cancel it
now no it's still seven months in one
day you know it's like good lord just
know just calm down not now not now not
now we'll wait we'll watch this
procrastination can be avoided
on the other hand if you're
procrastinating and not making a
decision
by setting a self-imposed deadline and
writing it on your calendar
i'm not going to decide now
i'm going to let this cook a little bit
inside my soul i'm going to gather some
more information i'm going to watch the
watch the marketplace move see how the
what rough the waters are and what's
going on
and by friday two weeks from today i'm
gonna make the call and just put on the
calendar
and when you wake up that morning you'll
be free
and you'll be going yeah i think i think
i can make oh by the way if i don't want
to make it that day i can purposefully
move the date
but at least you've got something
bearing down on you where you are going
not going to kick the can down the road
indefinitely
so you put a date on the calendar and
that pops up on ding ding okay today's
the day i got to make a decision am i
going to keep this person
i gave him a little time here i want to
make sure it wasn't just me being
emotional about it
and
i i think my initial i think my initial
thing was right i think we're gonna have
to go ahead and deal with this
and i don't just put it off and put it
off because of the pain
the pain that is inflicted with the
decision is usually short-term
the pain of not making a decision and
letting things just languish
is long-term and devastating to an
organization
take time proportionate to the size of
the decision
the more important the decision is the
bigger the impact of the decision the
more money is involved the more people
are involved the more important it is
the more time you should take
and here's what's interesting people do
they flip-flop this
they spend a lot of time deciding
which flavor of gum to buy
and they impulse a new porsche
you got that backwards
you want to spend a lot of time
analyzing an expensive purchase you
spend a lot of time analyzing a
five-year lease that you're in
negotiating that you're going to enter
into on a building that's a big deal
that's going to be with you for a long
time but don't spend the same amount of
time analyzing copier paper
so short easy little baby decisions make
them close the loop get that out of your
life that lowers your stress level and
opens up your bandwidth to spend the
proper amount of time on the big things
so make the little decisions quick and
get them off the plate get rid of the
mosquitoes so we can shoot bear
get after the big stuff
the bigger the decision the more
information you're going to need
information is king
there's a saying
roger yuri who wrote the book getting to
yes talks about the
negotiation for the ending of the war at
vietnam then ago some peace talks that
were done
he talks about the camp david accord and
he talks about several major
negotiations
and one of his key things in any
negotiation it's the consummate book on
negotiating
his key thing is he with the most
information and he with the most
patience
in a negotiation generally wins
if you can sit back and let the thing
drag out a little bit longer emotionally
than the other person can and you
understand their side almost better than
they do
you can you can generally win that
negotiation and the same is true with
decision making if you'll slow down
enough that you're very wise and the
more information you gather obviously
the more knowledgeable you are about the
situation the better the decision is
going to be
if there's a way to minimize the risk
make each part of the decision
bite-sized
make small parts of the decision to test
the decision or to move into it
gradually
that's an easier decision than biting
off the whole thing
so is there a way to iterate this
product is there a way to introduce this
product to a small group
we're working on a
a product right now that we're in beta
on
and uh getting ready to go into beta our
alpha and then we're going to go into
beta after the first of the year and so
we're going to start with a little group
of about 300 people and then we're going
to go to about 3 000 people and once we
kind of get all the bugs worked out then
we'll take it all the way now we've got
a lot invested in it at this point but
before we go with several more million
dollars of investment into it we will
have worked through the kinks
and we will have looked at this decis
we will have made the decision several
times again to go forward based on the
information we're gathering out of these
alpha and beta groups
of the decision matters what are the
financial implications of the decision
the biggest mistake people make in
business particularly small businesses
they do a james bond decision i call it
in every james bond movie at some point
during the movie he is at the card table
with the evil villain and they're
playing cards and the entire uh
you know the entire planet the
existence of the world as we know it is
dependent upon him winning this hand of
cards and he slides all of his chips to
the center of the table
no one in the real world should ever do
that
if your bet
on this product line
this idea this launch
is going to break your company and close
you down if it doesn't work
you shouldn't do it
you should make lots of mistakes in
business but they should all all be
course correction mistakes
not fatal errors
and a fatal error is when i put it all
on the line
and and somebody then will write a book
about that someday yeah they'll write a
book about how dumb you were
don't put it all on the line for one
deal for one thing don't risk the whole
thing for this one move
you work too hard to get to this point
to lose it all on one stinking decision
you don't need to be james bond
play the hand play the hand play the
hand
a little bit at a time a little bit of
time so we've had people come at us
especially in the past when when we were
smaller and they would bring us these
wonderful opportunities
only if the deal didn't work
the stuff was going to come back on us
we'd get all the products back
and we would lose all of that money
because they were all custom designed
products and we couldn't swallow that it
would have closed us
and so this huge blessing with this huge
company that was going to be our
benefactor they were going to be this
angel that comes in and gives us this
amazing deal would have also been the
company that bankrupted us
if we were stupid enough to take that
deal so i've turned down wonderful deals
that if they didn't work would have
closed us
no thanks
i don't need one single deal to make us
who we are we would rather win
death by a thousand cuts
ask the experts if you're making a
decision find people who know more about
something than you do
do not get confused that they are making
the decision though
sometimes they get confused that they're
making the decision
if you're a business person you should
never say i'm doing this because my
accountant told me to your accountant
works for you
you should understand it and you say the
accountant taught me this so this makes
sense and that's why i'm doing this
but you don't work for your accountant
the lawyer of the legal department said
we had to do this the hr department said
we had to do this no we don't they work
for me i don't work for them
they can come in and teach us what's
going on but we're going to make the
decision based on the information we
gather from the expert
don't acquiesce the decision-making
rights but gather information from
people about subjects you don't know
and that's a wonderful way to do it get
lots of information and so what you're
looking for with professionals
is not someone who is uh
arrogant you're looking for someone that
has the heart of a teacher
that's gonna teach you about what's
going on with this i've got amazing
amount of money spent on estate planning
and it's unbelievably complicated but he
doesn't tell us what we're going to do
we tell him what we're going to do and
then he figures out a way that we get to
do it
and how what's a mechanism what's a a
process we can use to get to that
an expert by the way is someone who has
actually done the thing
or has super specialized information in
a certain area not just someone that has
an opinion
now some of you are in here in the
you're in the business you're in a con
consulting role you're consultants
and in many industries there are
wonderful consultants that are excellent
at what they do and in a lot of
industries consultant simply means i'm
unemployed
and now i'm a damn expert
drive me nuts radio consultants are the
world's worst they're guys that want to
make it on the air never did so they
tell everybody what the on-air talent
should be doing
and they've never gotten a rating point
in their life
but they're a radio consultant shoot me
so
again there's valid consultants and i
laugh with a guy here than that he goes
i know how you feel about consultants i
don't hate all consultants that's not
the point but if you're going to deal
with a consultant make sure they
actually know something
that you know a marketing consultant is
someone who's actually done some
marketing not read a book once and then
bought business cards
so you know digital consulting is a big
deal i mean it's a problem in the
creative world it can be a real problem
and so just make real sure that these
consultants are people that have actual
hands-on experience and they actually do
know more than you know
because it's not always the case but try
to get those in your in your corner the
good ones and try to get people in your
corner that are pouring into you
and not just have not just has an
opinion
in the multitude of counsel
there's safety
scripture says that
so get counsel get experts around you
get people around you we'll talk it
through we're going to get lots of
opinions
and again in no case am i handing off my
right to make the decision or my
responsibility to make the decision but
i'm gathering info and input
and i know that i'm not all i don't have
all the answers just within myself and
so i want to gather all this stuff up
put it all out on the table and the
weird thing is the decision will just
stick its head up and tell you what to
do
you'll just go it'll just be right there
and you'll see it
if you if you gather information you get
the experts you get other people
involved you work it through in the
multitude of council and that includes
your spouse ask your spouse about major
decisions i've talked about that quite
about quite a bit this week from spousal
interviews to the sharon fund our
retained earnings account in the
who can find a virtuous wife for her
worth is far above rubies the heart of
her husband safely trusts her and he
will have no lack of gain talk to your
spouse about it now that's different
than just dumping and whining on your
spouse that's not what i'm talking about
i'm talking about they are one of your
counselors
on this issue
and they understand in this discussion
in this particular conversation what
we're doing here is we're looking at a
very big decision and the two of us need
to look at this together because it's
going to affect our marriage our family
for a long time this is a big deal what
do you think what do you feel
and this is not just
you know
any
some little drive-by thing it's you
frame the conversation in such a way
that your participation in this decision
with your spouse is your spouse's
participation is vital
because i want no lack of gain i like
that principle
it tells me what's going to happen right
i'm going to get no lack of gain if i do
this
so i want to frame it up in such a way
that i end up with that benefit
gather options options and more options
the more options you have the better
decision you're going to make
one of the most frustrating radio calls
i get
is people who have fatalistically
painted themselves into a corner
and they have two stupid options and
they want me to pick the one they like
dave we are we are in a house that has
mold
all in the house and our children are
going to die if we stay in the house
but there's no rental properties in the
entire area that aren't 75 of our income
so do we take a rental property with a
hou but with a payment of two thousand
dollars when we make three thousand
dollars a month it means we're going to
go bankrupt or do we stay in the house
and kill our children
which one should we do dave
i'm like
both are bad ideas
you don't have enough options you act
like there's two potential places in the
entire universe you could live in with
your family
you could leave that town
you could move to the country
you could move into an apartment
you could do buy a pop-up tent camper
that doesn't have mold
you could do a lot of stuff that you've
not put on the table as a discussion
but you know it's like okay i have to
choose between the death of my children
and my bankruptcy which should i choose
because this is all there is it's all
there is thought there is
and that's just complete horse crap it's
just not true
you need to gather more options so
anytime you feel like you're forced into
a decision between two dumb things it
means you don't have enough options you
need more options
and more and more and more options gives
you power
it changes everything
so we get ready to lease a building you
know years ago i would look at every
single piece of property that was for
lease or that i could find that anybody
would talk to me about possibly leasing
and i would spreadsheet it all i had i
knew more about that rental market
before i rented a building in it than
any commercial real estate agent did
because i had worked every detail and
every possible option and most of the
options suck they weren't good but i
knew they were there and i could use
them to set my tone
with the with the ten or five that were
reasonable and then begin to prioritize
those and get down to the one two or
three but if you think there's only one
possible thing you can do
you're about to get burned
you're about to make a bad decision and
you're you've lost all the power in your
negotiation because you've got no walk
away power
well in our business there's only one oh
horse crap
that is just not true
stop that
that's that all you're doing is saying
to yourself it's okay that i'm doing
something stupid
there's only one you know there's only
one way you can get
no it's not
there may be one dominant player that's
so dominant that they've got 98 percent
of the market but there's two percent
over here there's some little weirdo in
a garage somewhere you can work with
there's something you can do or by god
maybe that business and that industry
needs another player in it maybe you
need to open up
if there's only one player and they're
screwing everybody maybe it's time to
open up
there's a whole other way to get at this
thing
so you know
options options options options options
options always look for another way
you're entrepreneurs
but don't say stuff like there's only
exactly
walking through your worst case scenario
can eliminate fear
we had a major radio company come to us
uh many years ago and they we had six
major cities on that we were on the air
with them
and that's millions and millions and
millions of dollars a year not that they
pay us or we pay them
the way radio works in mainstream radio
is when you go into a commercial break
they own the local station has 70 of the
spots we've got 30 of spots so if
there's four spots in that break they
would have three local spots that they
sell to make money i have one national
spot that i sell to make money over the
whole network i make my money there they
make their money on the locals they
don't pay me anything i don't pay them
anything and that's the way hannity or
ramsey or whoever whichever talk radio
host you want to pick out does it in
mainstream radio christian radio you buy
the time but in mainstream radio we
barter it we split the revenues up and
they have zero payroll cost and i've got
zero expense well this company comes to
us and says uh well you guys are making
so much money as a result of being on
our radio stations that you are now
going to pay us six million dollars a
year
i salam i i i really don't think that's
fair
uh you don't charge any of the other
shows on you yeah but they don't
monetize like you do and i said so
because i'm actually a good business
person instead of a radio guy
you're thinking you're gonna milk me
well it just seems like right it seems
right that you should share that revenue
and i said no it doesn't seem right to
me
so we had a
unfriendly discussion and i said well i
guess we'll just have to get back to you
you want to give us a little time to
kind of process this and yeah yeah but
this is this is the way it's going to be
you're going to pay us
probably not but we'll talk about it
okay
so i was pretty pissed off
i'm about to lose
six big cities or i'm about to write
some checks that i really shouldn't have
to write this is pretty much extortion i
was pretty angry
and i was angry partly because i was
afraid i didn't want to lose all those
cities and all that revenue and all that
impact and all those people's lives that
we could touch and it was
it just
and so i just said well all right what's
the worst case scenario worst case
scenario is uh we say no thank you and
they take us off the air
and we don't have those sick cities
anymore and we just go on with our lives
and we figure out a way to do it that's
our worst case
and you know we sat on that a little bit
and kind of got used to it
life without them
and you know it took about three or four
days
and after three or four days emotionally
i was already working without them
it eliminated the fear
once i said what's the worst case
scenario is i lose the markets
completely and never go back on again in
my life
you know which is not true that's over
that's melodrama
and so once i decided that
then i took the next three weeks and
went to other radio groups in those six
cities
and and found a new home in four of the
cities
and then i went back to the guy and i
said well we're gonna have to pass on
your generous offer
and uh he said we're gonna take you off
the air and i said i know you told me
that and he goes you're kidding you're
just not you're just gonna walk away and
i said
would you you really thought that dave
ramsey i mean what part of knowing me
did you think this was gonna work
and he goes i just can't believe you're
just gonna you're just gonna give this
up and i said no i'm not giving it up
i'm actually going on your competitor
i'm gonna kick your ass
[Applause]
eight years later we spoke again at a
radio convention we're friends again now
he's a good guy but
he made a mistake on that one um
so you walk through your worst case
scenario and it eliminates fear people
call me up they're like i'm losing my
house what do i do the foreclosure's
gonna happen i'm like when
i just lost my job today are you current
on your payments yeah well you're not
gonna lose your house
i'm a little bit foreclosed on no you're
not
you mean you just lost your job today go
get another job
you're not even late on your if you
don't pay a payment for nine months
maybe you can call me and we'll talk
about you being foreclosed on that's
probably about how long it's going to
take before they get around to it that's
the normal with an fha or a conventional
loan so you're not going to get
foreclosed on but let's just pretend for
a second that it was friday and you were
going to get foreclosed on friday
what would you do
if you were going to lose your house
friday
calm down what would you do if you're
going to lose your house friday
i guess i would just go
find some place to rent that would rent
to somebody they've been foreclosed on
yeah that's what you'd do
there's another house
and you'd start again and you'd build
your credit back up and pay your
landlord on time and then you'd go buy
you another house right
yeah i mean so it's gonna be okay
so you're not gonna get foreclosed on
but if you do it's still gonna be okay
and the fear just goes
just drops
once you work through emotionally the
worst case scenario and you go the worst
case scenario is this client that we
really like is a huge client we're going
to lose them
and we're going to lose all that revenue
once you
align yourself to that emotionally you
set yourself in a completely different
decision-making paradigm because here's
what happens when you're in fight or
flight like deloney was talking about
with his bricks talk
your brain gets coated
with chemicals and your critical
thinking skills disappear
fear is not your friend
for critical thinking skills
you have got to slow down and step back
from fear in order for your your
creative thoughts to kick in and your
ways to solve your problem-solving
skills to to show up again and so you've
got to push that stuff back in order to
make good clean decisions
train your team to bring you several
possible solutions not just problems
this is actually a training a trainable
skill this decision making thing
so what happens is
guy comes into your office
and he brings you an emergency he brings
you
she brings you a problem
and she sets it on your desk
and turns to walk out oh no no no no
one of the rules is you bring the
problem you get to participate in the
solution
what do you mean well let's look at the
problem for a minute here's what we're
going to do
you tell me what should we do with this
problem i have no idea that's why i
brought it in here well let's look at it
because i'm not going to do this all day
long
so you need to learn to deal with this
so so what should we do with this well
we could do this we could do a okay
that's pretty good
and
we maybe could do b yeah that would work
and what about this what about c yeah
that's good there's three ideas now i
want you to leave for a few minutes and
i want you to look at those a b and c
ideas and i want you to decide which of
those you think is the best one i want
you to come back in here and tell me how
you're going to solve this
and they come back in and they go well i
really think that a is the best way and
i think that a is pretty good and i like
your thinking on that but actually
here's what you should do you should do
b
and here's why we're going to do b
instead of a and here's how it works and
here's why we're doing this and here's
what you're going to do now take the
problem and go do b
and don't come in here again
like that
you can come in here with problems but
don't come in here with just the problem
okay
now the smart one will come back in the
next time you go okay here's a problem
but
i got a and i got b what do you think
those are pretty good
here's c you could do that yeah here's d
you could do that yeah now let's talk
through it which one based on what we
did last time when we saw the same kind
of thing what did we do and you're
training them to
come to the same conclusions you would
have come to you following me
and so then they come back in the office
later and they go okay here's a problem
and here's a b c and d and i've already
looked at it and based on what you
taught me the last six times i was in
here
we're going to do b
and you go very good
excellent
leave my office and go do b
the next time there's a problem they'll
walk by your office and go we had a
problem i fixed it and they'll keep
walking
[Applause]
steve brown's an old motivator from the
70s and he used to talk about this when
they come into your office with a
problem you need to visualize they have
a monkey on their shoulder
and when they say we have a problem you
have a problem you need to visualize
that monkey jumps off their shoulder in
the middle of your desk
[Laughter]
your job
if you want to run a business and not a
zoo
is to make sure when they leave your
office they take their monkey
otherwise at the end of the day you're
going to be having monkeys all in your
office
and you can't get nothing done you're
running a zoo and so every time somebody
walks in and goes oh
i just see monkey in the middle of my
desk
now i'm gonna go okay we're gonna talk
about this but i'm gonna keep my eye on
the monkey because i want to be sure
that when he leaves the monkey goes with
him
so that i can get back to doing what i
was doing before he came in here and
interrupted my day
so this is what this is what we're doing
we're teaching decision making paradigm
you need to be able to finish my
sentences if you're going to be one of
my leaders you need to know this is the
way we're going to react and act these
are the principles by which we make
decisions here's the things we don't do
here's the things we do do and that
leads us into these four possibilities
not 18 possibilities and you're going to
know the general direction that we're
going to go with those most of the time
and the leaders have been with me 10 20
years it's we can just finish each
other's sentences
just to smooth the silk
and some of the things i've learned from
them by the way so i've adjusted what i
do to the stuff they have taught me and
that's fine too
skills and things that they've brought
to the process
let your values guide you follow the
golden rule that's one of the things
we're always going to do treat other
people like you won't be treated
when you're 72 and you're on your
deathbed are you going gonna be glad you
did it this way
that'll keep you calm
keep you from doing something when
you're frustrated
keep you generous
you know just kind of think long term
with this ten years from today who's
gonna care about this okay
or is this a 10-minute emergency
don't let your principles change but
frequently change your processes
you have key things that are who you are
these are principles we never change
these principles but we change processes
how we do it all the time
now
if you never change
processes but you change your principles
frequently you're what's known as a
bureaucrat
quite the opposite a frustrating process
so processes i mean when i started al
gore hadn't even invented the internet
yet so
i got this whole new thing by the time
i'm gone we'll be doing this with
holograms or something right
so but but the process i don't give a
crap whether it's a podcast or a radio
show or a youtube channel i don't care
it's still the same stupid thing i'm
saying over and over and over again live
on less than you make
get out of debt live on a budget but i
can do that in a whole bunch of
different mediums and medias and
settings i'm agnostic to that we can do
whatever the process is what's the most
effective process what's the best way to
do this how do we negotiate with sirius
xm how do we work with youtube
how do you do all this stuff right
and so the processes are change all the
time
we live in a high rate of change world
but the principles that drive you into
those processes cannot change and
that'll help you make decisions
like you know here's an here's an
example
i made the decision a long time ago our
organization has adopted that decision
and codified that decision that we have
this principle if you steal
we're not going to bother with you
you're leaving
that day
that's a principle and so when someone
comes in and they go hey this guy that
we all love and he's a great guy and
he's really doing a good job but you
know here he is he's leaving with stuff
every night he's taking stuff the car
he's just stealing stuff you go yeah
that's awful sad
because the decision is already made now
the only pain now is executing on the
decision
because now i got to go to this guy i
love who's a thief and go you're gone
and i have to have this hard
conversation and you're out of here
right but i'm not going to change the
principle the decision was already made
as soon as we discover the mess
instantaneously but now i got to go
through the whole thing and figure it
out oh man it's awful
if all else fails write yourself a
report describing the problem and by the
time you finish writing yourself a
report you'll probably have the answer
as if you were reporting to someone else
again when you transfer general jobbled
up
chaotic thoughts into
written form there's something that
happens there that makes you process the
information more thoroughly refine it
more thoroughly distill it more
thoroughly and therefore you'll come
quickly to a much better
decision
here's the interesting thing
if you are a person who struggles to
make decisions if you'll use these
processes we talked about
and encourage yourself to start making
decisions people who make decisions
at the speed that their personality
style asks them to but they are decisive
at slow or fast speeds there are people
who make decisions have much less
anxiety and stress
unmade decisions are stressful
problems in front of you not being
addressed are more stressful than a
problem that has been dealt with
even if the outcome is negative
it's still less stressful to deal with
it and close the loop
you got to close the loop in your brain
making decisions sets
you
free